hello my name is Nolan Phillips and I'm
the representative from the state of
Kentucky
now this is the birthplace of the town
I'm from which is Lexington which is the
second largest city in Kentucky after
Louisville it's got about three hundred
thousand inhabitants and this is
McConnell Springs which is actually a
nature park right now it's a nature
reserve and McConnell Springs is so
named because William McConnell who was
a pioneer and Explorer and his followers
came here and made a settlement here
because of the natural freshwater
Springs there are just over there now
there are many places you can see in
Lexington in there are many things you
can do in the Bluegrass region which is
the region of Kentucky where a Lexington
is kind of central northern kentucky and
so if you wanted to come to central
Kentucky you can see Ashland which is
very interesting it's the estate of
prominent Kentucky statesman Henry Clay
who lived here in the early 1800s and
you would be also be able to see some
horse farms where a lot of thoroughbreds
and a lot of Kentucky Derby winners of
course the Kentucky Derby is actually
held in Louisville but a lot of Kentucky
Derby winners are from Lexington because
Lexington's considered the horse capital
of the world and it's where a lot oh I
mean an enormous amount of thoroughbreds
are bred so there's also a fairly famous
race track here called Keeneland so you
can see a race there and in the general
region there are some very interesting
things to see geologically speaking on
the Kentucky River now the Kentucky
River does not go through Lexington it
goes through Frankfurt which is the
State Capitol but Lexington is not
actually on any kind
waterbody the vast majority of the bread
rock here is made of limestone so there
are a lot of karsts there are a lot of
which are you know it's a watery
underground limestone area and there are
a lot of underground caves next to the
Kentucky River there are some Palisades
which are very interesting they're like
steep very steep sometimes sheer cliffs
that are carved out by the river the
place probably that I would like to go
most in the world or we definitely
towards the top of my list probably be
the kingdom of Bhutan which is a small
country and Central Asian the Himalayan
mountains and Bhutan has been has had
virtually no exposure to the modern
world for a long time and in the modern
day with the influx of you know
computers and the internet and cell
phones and TV and modern devices the
government and the people are trying to
retain a lot of their cultural heritage
and they're trying to preserve their
cultural heritage and they have this
thing called a gross gross national
happiness survey which is a survey just
to see how things are going in the
country and i think so i think the
language is very pretty too in bhutan
it's a it's closely related to tibetan
it's called ruka
and I also believe that bhutan has some
of the most beautiful natural sites in
the world as it's right at the foothills
of the Himalayan mountains so there are
a lot of beautiful things relating to
the Himalayas and you know valleys and
mountain valleys so that maybe that
would probably be the place in the world
where I would like to go to most
alright National Geographic did you know
that Kira boss is the only country it's
an island country in the Pacific it's
the only country that's right at the
crosshairs of the international date
line and the equator which means that
before 1995 when a law was passed
regulating otherwise you could travel
from one island to another island in the
same country and technically be in a
different season on a different day
you